especially for a guy that's having this  during the year  [Applause]  bradley fouls morant they get tied up  and now  getting into it on the floor  steven adams literally lifting him up  tony bradley who is not a small guy he  literally just lifted him up and carried  him away  from john moran tony bradley is 6-7  220. and adam's just  hoist him  i think john moran he got fouled but he  seemed to be more the instigator in the  battle  but steven adams always going to protect  his teammates  and he did so here  bradley wouldn't let go even after  morant pushed the ball in his face and  steven adams just said all right here  let me take you over here with me i  think marant took exception to where  bradley's knee  oh sure directed right there and  it'll be interesting how they rule this  fans are now getting a look at the  replays as well it all depends on where  you see it obviously the three officials  will